you've said that China won't move on
Taiwan militarily in part because it's
uh as you said amphibious operations are
difficult why will China not move on
Taiwan is in your
sense uh in the near future well it's
because there's this body of water
called the Taiwan Strait which is a big
body of water and getting across water
uh is very difficult ult unless you can
walk on water so geography still has a
role to play in the 21st century oh yeah
I think geography is very important big
bodies of water really matter yeah in an
Ideal World you'd like to have the
Pacific Ocean between you and any
potential adversary you know 6,000 miles
yes 6,000 miles of water hard to get
across I if you're a country and I'm a
country and there's land between us I
can take my Panzer divisions and I can
go right across the land and get into
your country or attack your country and
you of course can take your Panzer
divisions and come across that same
piece of land but if there's a big body
of water between us your Panzer
divisions can't go across the water and
then the question is how do you get them
across the water and that's very tricky
and in a world we have lots of
submarines and you have lots of aircraft
and you have missiles that are landbased
that can hit those surface ships it it
is very very hard to you know to attack
across a body of water and all you have
to do is think about uh Normandy you
know the American invasion of Normandy
June 6 1944 coming in on Omaha Beach
right uh oh boy that was really
difficult but there is a growing
asymmetry of military power there that
even though it's difficult that is
correct so I I guess that is correct so
I recently had a conversation with Elon
Musk and he
says
that uh you know China is quite serious
about the one China policy and it seems
inevitable that Taiwan will have to be
if you look at this pragmatically in the
21st century it seems inevitable that
Taiwan will have to be a part of China
and so we can get there either
diplomatically or militarily like um
what do you think about the
inevitability of that kind of idea when
a nation says this is a top
priority for us
um what do you think about them meaning
it and what do we do about that there's
no question it's a top priority for them
and there's no question they mean it but
it's also a top priority for us not to
let them take Taiwan why exactly because
it's it's an important strategic asset
uh many people will say it's because
taiwan's a democracy but that doesn't
matter that
much uh it's
because uh of two strategic reasons the
first is that uh if we were to let
Taiwan
go it would have hugely negative
consequences for our alliance structure
in East Asia to contain China we need
allies we have an alliance structure and
Arab allies Japanese South
Koreans Filipinos
Australians they're all counting on us
to be there for them and if we say we're
not going to defend Taiwan the Chinese
attack they're going to say I bet if the
Chinese attack us the Americans won't be
there for us uh so the it would have
uh a damaging effect on our alliance
structure which we cannot afford cuz cuz
containing China is a wicked problem
it's a powerful State you were getting
to this before when you talked about
China versus Taiwan so that's the first
reason second reason is you want to
bottle up the Chinese Navy and the
Chinese Air Force inside the first
island chain you don't want to let them
get
out uh into the Pacific you don't want
them dominating the Waters of East Asia
you want to bottle them up again inside
the first island chain and you can only
do that if you control Taiwan you don't
control Taiwan they get out into the
Philippine Sea into the Pacific and the
Western Pacific and cause all sorts of
problems well you saying all that you've
also said the century of humiliation
Japan and the United States are a source
of that humiliation for
China don't you think they see the other
side of that absolutely and in the
interest of avoiding being a World
War I guess the question is uh how do we
avoid a World War it
doesn't um seem like the military invol
involvement in the conflict between
China and Taiwan is the
way well I I don't want there's no good
answers here I'm just saying there are
no good which is the the less bad option
well what you want to do is you want to
make sure that you
deter uh from invading Taiwan you want
to avoid a war you and I are in a
complete agreement on that we don't want
a war but we want to contain China we do
not want to let China dominate Asia that
that's what the Americans are
principally concerned with here and it's
what China's neighbors are prably
concerned with this includes the
Japanese the South Koreans Filipinos
Australians and the Taiwanese we they
don't want and we don't want China to
dominate the region so we have to
contain it
but at the same time and this should be
music to your ears we not only want to
contain it we want to make sure we don't
end up in a shooting match with the
Chinese because this could be disastrous
so you have to have a very smart policy
you have to build powerful military
forces and you have to make sure you
don't do anything that's provocative on
Taiwan for example the last thing you
want is for the Taiwanese government to
declare its independence because the
Chinese have said if Taiwan does that
we'll go to war and of course we don't
want that so my view is you want to
smartly build up your military forces
and you want to do everything you can to
contain China uh and at the same time
not be
provocative so a big component of that
is making uh sure your military the US
military is bigger than the Chinese
military not necessarily uh it's an
interesting question
uh a lot of people think that to make
deterrence work right you have to be
able to beat the Chinese and therefore
you need a much bigger
military uh and I don't think over time
that's possible right I think it's
probably not even possible now to beat
the Chinese in a war over Taiwan or in a
war in the South China Sea I think what
you want to do is make it clear to the
Chinese either that there will be no
winner in other words you don't have to
win but you want to make sure they don't
win okay it's it's it's a l lose U
proposition if they go to war over
Taiwan or what have you uh and if you
can't do that right you think that
they're so powerful that they're
ultimately going to win you want to
convince them that Victory would be a
pic victory in other words they would
pay a god- awful price to win the war if
follow what I'm saying so excuse me the
best strategy for deterrence is you win
China loses second best strategy is a
stalemate nobody wins third best
strategy is they win but they pay a God
awful price and the fourth possibility
which you don't want is they win quickly
and decisively right uh if that's the
case then you don't have much deterrence